a Dutch is just another bad guy well you
just tell me what really happened he
took one look at me decided I was the
guy that guy could still be out there I
have some friends that could help we are
gonna need a confession from dr.
Schreiber see if we got bigger problems
okay guys I'm like this go sighs now you
guys it will literally change the way
that we think about everything it's more
than just karma it's the principle of
infinite consequences at work in our
lives it's always expanding creating
positive songs on an infinite basis hey
everybody we got new flash to break down
in next week's episode thankfully will
continue teasing out the mystery of a
lot of the bigger things that we've seen
the last couple of weeks behind the
scenes and in the episodes we got those
mystery symbols at the end of last
week's episode there's also the idea
that women on the show who are either
confirmed pregnant or might be pregnant
have temporary powers which I know
sounds confusing but I'll try to explain
it there's also a new round of that
blasts ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter just be a subscriber and share
the video using those tools on the watch
page there so let's start with the
actual footage that we see in the
trailer first there's a lot of stuff
that they didn't put in this but you
have Barry trying to help out Goldberg
because he was wrongfully accused of
murder the cops just decided that I was
the guy so that provides the tip-off for
Team flash to go after the real culprit
who winds up being the meta of the
episode who because Goldberg has been in
prison for a long time doesn't sound
like he's going to be one of the bus
metas even though it's been a little
while since we've touched with one of
the bus metas and they're supposed to be
12 total
maybe they'll roll like three out at
once if they fall behind pace but
they're doing that very Honey I Shrunk
the kids thing you know Honey I Shrunk
team flash I haven't watched those
movies in a long time but the whole idea
is is that he's a meta who's supposed to
be able to shrink people by touching
them but in the trailer he seems like
he's more ex-military like he shoots the
gun at them and it seems like the gun is
what shrinking them so it's still a
little confusing about how his powers
work they haven't revealed what his
name is so we don't know if he's a
comic-book character but we do know that
berry actually says the name of an arrow
villain from the Black Canary arrow
comics from a long time ago which is
kind of funny so minor arrow crossover
turns out there's an arrow villain
somewhere inside prison here like he
says Dodger Dodger was one of those
really despicable characters that helped
out team arrow in the comics briefly he
had a lot of technology but he wasn't
like a super-powerful meta or anything
like that he had like his electric mace
he has some technology that they call
deus ex machina which just takes people
out over a wide radius so I don't think
they're gonna do anything crazy with the
character the writers have explained in
the past that sometimes like when they
do their final pass on the script if
there are a lot of characters and they
just have like a long list of names that
they can give them this somehow ties
them to the comics in a really creative
way then they'll do that but it seems
like Dodger of the TV show will just
wind up being part of one of these
prison gangs that they're really
focusing on Goldberg is being the big
character with Barry in here in addition
to the warden in the bus Metis who we
still haven't seen since Barry has been
in prison there but he's in gen-pop
there in the metahuman wing so maybe if
he's still in there in the next two
weeks then we'll bump into them because
it would be weird for you to go to iron
Heights without touching on some of the
big people that they locked up at the
beginning of the season how will I
survive in here without my Kindle do you
in touch in anything electronic ever
again there's three layers of signal
dampening walls between you and the
world no wiring not even a light bulb
there's technology everywhere these days
as far as Goldberg's character I don't
think they're doing any huge comic book
storyline when he was first introduced
he was taken advantage of by the Rogues
he was like a simple-minded person the
Rose tricked him into thinking that the
flash did something terrible
so he went after the flash but then
eventually found the truth out he became
part of the Suicide Squad later in the
comics it was just sort of a minor
character but I think they're just
trying to prove that Barry is still
trying to be the flash even though he's
behind bars like he's always gonna try
and help people and that will come back
around maybe by the end of the season
who knows if he'll come back but if
Barry clears his name
maybe they'll pay that off in the next
couple of episodes like you helped get
me out of prison so I'm gonna do you big
solid - that will help him out with his
fight against the thinker
so circling back around to iris dawn
West Cecille and babies at the end of
the season part of the episode
description reads the cecile temporarily
gets powers from her pregnancy
specifically gets powers because she's
pregnant it's the ability to read minds
and they say that it's disconcerting to
Joe meaning that she'll just hear him
thinking things that he doesn't want her
to know like he's really bummed out
about Barry or just really awkward
things that put Joe in a weird situation
like just using it for straight-up
comedy but like I said they TF abilities
really early in the season like give you
this really funny idea like iris being
sucked into the Speed Force with Barry
in the middle of that trial room how is
this possible
well we'll probably explain it later
this season so the last couple of days
everyone's seen iris West wearing a very
XS looking costume from behind the
scenes that might imply that she gets
powers like Cecile because she might be
pregnant and that would explain how
she's able to exist in the Speed Force
in this moment with Barry
was happening
so quickly that everyone else is still
high Jesus of me I actually don't know I
know it's a little confusing like why
would they give them temporary powers
what's the whole point of that well it's
all in service
I think of we're going to need more
diapers and I think that mystery person
at the end of the episode here from the
future riding down Speed Force cymbals
she's one of those babies so it all
makes sense when you stack it together
berry comes out of the Speed Force
riding cymbals you see people on the
show getting powers temporarily because
of pregnancy when you normally wouldn't
expect those people to get powers and
then you see somebody mysteriously come
from the future that knows a lot about
the characters but who we've never seen
before and is trying to act like she's a
total stranger to total strangers you
know we're short on cash and then
someone just steps out of the blue and
helps out I don't so what'll happen is
is either Thursday or Friday I'll do a
video trying to explain who that person
is and how this all ties together like
people getting mystery powers what the
speedforce symbols are all about in how
this might help them in their fight
against the thinker because remember
they're not just doing it to introduce
characters like Bart Allen or the
tornado twins all of these separate plot
lines that seem like they have no
connection we'll all tied together by
the last couple of episodes always pay
no worse usually by the time you head
into the finale you already know what
all the big mysteries are and then what
they'll do like the big surprise of the
finale is teeing up what's going to
happen during the next season so I do
think a lot of the stuff that they're
doing right now these big mysteries the
dawn allen person from the future is
teeing up season five stuff but we
really won't find out what they're
actually gonna do with season five til
the last couple of episodes of the
season so what'll happen next is I'll do
my black lightning video we also found
out when we're getting a new Deadpool
trailer and there might be a new Han
Solo trailer sometime this week so well
mean that new giveaway winner when I
post that black lightning video in a
couple hours
click here for my flash Easter eggs and
click here for that iris West speedster
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight